Francis Huster a été mon prof de théâtre
non
Caroline notre célèbre chanson c'est la
ouate aura 30 ans l'an prochain 30 ans
c'est les noces de coton c'est ça non
[Musique]
Caroline vous êtes né le 5 octobre 1955
à Neuilly-sur-Seine votre grand-père
étant un marchanda exceptionnel quand
votre père a voulu monter sa galerie
pour exister il a dû s'exiler à New York
oui c'est comme ça que j'ai passé mon
enfance à New York de 4 à 10 ans devant
Central Park tout près de John Lennon
d'une enfance extraordinaire comme on
voit dans Mad Men voilà c'est exactement
ça là vous découvrez l'opéra je découvre
la musique j'écoute Yvette Gilbert tout
le temps Boby Lapointe l'opéra je me
shoote à Verdi à Mozart voilà donc
j'étais dingue de musique mais vraiment
toute petite à la fin des années 70 la
réalité est plus prosaïque vous
retrouvez vendeuse chez Kenzo je voulais
être comédienne mon père m'a dit si tu
veux te payer tes cours de théâtre va
travailler et donc c'est comme ça que je
suis devenu vendeuse chez Kenzo vous
avez connu Francis Huster Francis Huster
a été mon prof de théâtre j'imagine non
pas particulièrement c'est ce qu'il dit
avec lui-même
alors à 23 ans vous montez sur les
planches avec les Argentins de Paris qui
avaient fui le régime de Buenos Aires
des amis d'Alfredo Arias et vous faites
du théâtre avec ces gens-là absolument
c'était formidable là si oui envoie à
New York dans le studio électrique
Ladyland le studio de Jimi Hendrix qui
était en pleine démolition à l'époque
pour faire un disque avec les musiciens
de kit créole en fait c'est là que j'ai
fait mon premier album et le coût de la
démolition quand on est arrivé le studio
n'était pas encore en démolition mais on
a fait le dernier mix de la dernière
chanson
narcissique au milieu des gravats on
était dans un état
vraiment très proche de l'Ohio et on
entendait Jimi Hendrix et en fait c'est
la chanson la plus réussie de l'album
mais c'était vraiment c'était la guerre
quoi quand on a fait ce mix alors là
vous faites ensuite des pochettes de
disques avec mon Dino un livre sur les
poupées avec Serge Gainsbourg vous
devenez attacher de presse des Bains
Douches c'est vous qui lancez les Bains
Douches en fait à Paris et un jour un
copain de virer nocturne Pierre Grillet
débarque chez vous avec plein de petites
phrases sur son carnet dont de tous les
matières c'est la ouate qu'elle préfère
ensuite Shani
mais ce texte en musique et personne ne
veut de la chanson c'est une histoire
classique c'est vraiment il y a beaucoup
de choses qui sont des grands succès le
seul secret c'est de pas lâcher de
s'accrocher et c'est vrai qu'après quand
la chanson a été signée par Constantin
chez Barclay ça a été ça a été vraiment
une traînée de poudre c'était vraiment
incroyable c'est une folie furieuse
cette chanson c'est à dire qu'en très
peu de temps c'est devenu non seulement
un tube en France mais à l'international
c'est numéro en Italie numéro 1 dans
plein de pays alors il y a eu plein de
reprises en fait de cette chanson
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi tu demandes ça parce que je
t'ai entendu toute la semaine chanter de
toutes les matières et c'est la ouate
que je préfère moi je pensais que
c'était encore quelque chose d'interdit
comme souvent ici
[Applaudissements]
alors voilà c'est la watmania vous êtes
cité par François Mitterrand dans une
interview d'Yves Mourousi vous avez
déjeuner à l'Elysée quand même
à vous non
pour la deuxième fois de l'émission
madame monsieur c'est le drame
[Musique]
c'est le drame vous vous embrouillez
avec votre côte-auteur oui oui non mais
c'est vrai que voilà quand on est dans
la lumière et puis des fois derrière ça
pousse un peu mais c'est normal
et vous devenez ce qu'on appelle une one
eat Wonder ça veut dire pour ma mère les
gens qui n'ont fait qu'un succès
vous racontez tout ça très bien en livre
chez Flammarion
un jour je descends de scène et il y a
une femme qui m'arrête qui me fait vous
êtes les vrais parce que souvent on nous
envoie des faux je me suis dit
pas vraiment une chanteuse vous êtes
devenu une chanson une chanson un peu
envahissante quand même efficace
ça c'est la Corée
alors juste pour savoir vous êtes à la
MAAF vous non vous êtes même pas
si votre assurance vie la MAAF quand
même
je suis déjà à la masse de fête du
pognon sérieux bien sûr ah ouais je suis
coteurs parce que c'est la meuf ça va
vite tu vois donc même multiplié par 100
c'est pas énorme mais ça permet de faire
tourner la bière comme on dit je ne vois
plus de bière donc ça paye les olives
alors attendez qu'est-ce qui sont
devenus les autres là pierre grillée il
est devenu quoi la pierre grillé il
vient de sortir un roman qui paraît-il
est formidable mais que j'ai pas encore
lu qui s'appelle madame rêve parce qu'il
a quand même écrit ce chef-d'oeuvre
absolu pour Bashung
il doit être milliardaire non je ne sais
pas vous l'avez vu c'est un peu
compliqué avec lui
[Rires]
si c'était à refaire toute cette
histoire m'avait répondu je prendrai un
bon avocat
sans commentaire donc c'est vrai
heureusement vous ne vous êtes pas
arrêté là la preuve du 3 au 26 juillet
vous serez sur la scène du théâtre le
coin de la lune à Avignon c'est co-écrit
avec Tom Dingler et mise en scène par
Alex luth c'est une très bonne bande là
vraiment vous êtes au mieux là
bah là oui là je suis très très bien
c'est vrai que c'est voilà c'est mon
spectacle autour de George sandales
George Sand ma vie s'en œuvre j'adore le
titre moi je me suis vraiment passionnée
pour la vie de cette femme qui est
extraordinaire et on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de bonheur à travailler
là-dessus c'est-à-dire que c'est une
femme qui est totalement
enthousiasmante et c'est vraiment devenu
ma meilleure amie ah oui alors juste une
question à quel moment vous chantez
c'est la ouate dans le spectacle il y a
un tout petit clin d'oeil assez la ouate
qui marche très bien et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu